des hommes et leur combat quotidien
lapointe de fous là après deux jours
fériés et les engins l'arrêt il y ait la
nécessité de gérer des sargasses en un
temps court pour éviter les émanations
de gaz toxiques
on est là pour une ap hp c'est vrai que
si on est un éternel recommencement
mais c'est par rapport aux à la façon
aussi boire parce que le chef d'equipe
avait déjà tout un truc il ya eu 10
watts heure par rapport à ton je vous ai
dit plus tôt ou au point de stockage
qu'on n'avait pas ses doutes la db9 allé
beaucoup trop loin alors ça nous amener
beaucoup un problème maintenant qu'on a
récupéré le corps de stockage je pense
qu'on va pouvoir rattraper et éviter
d'avoir ce genre de choses là sur la
plage nous sommes 14 si je ne me trompe
pas un autre équipe au bout qui sont
cause
et puis c'est bourré de pioches et de
temps en temps avec la participation de
la commune qui nous donne une à deux
heures de tractor cette équipe d'agents
devant le cpa ou bien ici ils sont en
contrat d'insertion
il y a quelques mois ils ne se
connaissaient pas ou très peu
en intégrant l'association le lien s'est
créé et même renforcé sur le plan
professionnel certains on trouvait des
opportunités de faire quelques
formations
nous sommes très bien sûr nous avons des
sujets sociaux
nous avons des formations que nous
passons comme le cas c est comme l'est
était fait que ce coup-ci c'est un truc
que j'avais toujours rêvé d'avoir
et bien c'est aussi à l'association il
ya quelques jeunes là qu'ils ont passé
leur place et à d'autres casas a passé
nos problèmes nous-mêmes familiaux et
nos problèmes personnels
nous avons déjà sociales qui sont dans
l'association qui sont là à nous occuper
le plus grand soin et si tu ne sais pas
que de la grèce qui finissent par avant
la qualification l'europe michi qu'ils
ont dix joueuses au départ que qu on les
rapproche le ministre possible pour
entendre le fil de l'eau
les équipes espèrent terminer ce gros
ramassage dimanche ces hommes et ces
femmes continueront ce travail ici tant
que d'autres opérations n'auront pas été
validés